[Applause] it's always so weird seeing you in this
setting yeah I love it try to pretend like this is
Mario do you know each other we did just meet oh
okay I mean I feel like I've known him of course
congratulations on everything nomination all of
it too I thank you I remember though when you and
Brandy Clark started like a decade ago it was a
decade ago yes I think I even went to smack songs
I think I went to your place when yall were riding
one day for but I was like this has been a passion
project for a minute it has been and I mean we
really didn't know anything so our na Nativity
nativity naivity naivity scene nativity scene
nativity scene it really helped though because
you know people along the way especially when we
get into the Broadway World we'd be like oh we're
writing a Broadway musical and they'd be like
H good luck and you know well because so many
people try to do it and they also I thought you
know we'll will definitely go faster than what
they say because most of these shows take 10
years a lot of work and and it took 10 years
every bit of it it's actually the same changed
it's morphed it's the same age as like at my kids
I'm just say it was yeah sorry to interrupt you
but yeah it's the the the week we first started
uh her and Robert horn the bookwriter they came to
Palm Springs where the kids were born yeah and we
sat down and we all started working that week so
the age of the kids has more and they're almost
11 so uh oh my gosh yeah so the show has changed
I mean it it's more many times we had an out of
town back in Texas uh six years ago we had another
out of town in Salt Lake that's what you do is you
kind of get it in front of an audience and let
you know let them tell you what works and what
doesn't work and yeah it it it's been an amazing
experience so the greatest thrill Pony nominated
that's incredible who would have thought mineral
wells just making it on the map minerals I love
it you you did Broadway as well was it a I did a
course on that's right that's what happened to met
my wife so Broadway is always special to me and
I love I love musicals oh wait nice outfit I love
it I'm looking at that cuz I keep going what are
they looking at pictures so explain shucked for
everybody because it's had many lives but what did
it end up being so it is the story it's a fable
it's set in this fictional Place sort of in the
middle of the country we assume called Cobb County
and basically everything they do uh revolves
around corn they've they've made their life around
corn yeah uh they grow it they sell it they eat it
they live off of it and you can surprisingly do a
lot of things with corn I mean we actually wrote a
song call Corn that opens the show that lists like
200 ways that you can use corn it's amazing it
is Iowa what Iowa do Forest Gump with shrimp it's
exactly you're like sweet corn yeah exactly so
wait the cast is performing later right what's the
song they're doing so they're doing a song called
We love Jesus actually interesting enough it's
the first song we wrote for the show 11 years ago
and it got taken out many times during the years
and right or throughout the years and right before
we opened three days before we opened on Broadway
they put it back in what yeah because uh we had
tried different things to open the second act I
mean you know how like sometimes you get in front
of an audience and some things work song they did
at the Macy's Thanksgiving no that was corn that's
the open that I was going to say okay CU I know I
saw it at the corn you know very creative name for
a show about corn and so this song is uh called we
love Jesus and um I'm so excited it it probably
will seem a little strange out of context because
it it has a a guy that you're going to meet soon
who is sort of an outsider in this world yeah and
so he's the city guy that's sort of hatching a
plan to to take some things from these people
take advantage yeah exactly thank you for helping
me through this nity I feel like I'm on one of the
game shows and Kelly and I we're gonna win um so
anyway he's kind of uh being pushed around in this
number and it's really cute but if you haven't
seen it or no you'd be like what is that white
dude doing in the middle of all these people
getting pushed out of town yeah you know now
that's the best tease ever everybody can't wait
to see this number now exactly joining us now
are two of the performers from the show everybody
say hello and give it up to gray Henson and John
Bellman I have to say you both look sharp but
that suit is like my favorite well I know I wish I
could take credit but it's a costume from the show
oh my God I love it yeah everyone backstage in the
makeup room Miami Vice like but in the 70 like
I just I'm very into it so explain everybody who
your characters are well so I Am The Outsider in
the show the aforementioned uh white man um um and
uh and so I'm I'm a I'm a Florida man basically
so you nailed it right on like na that giving
Florida man then and I'm kind of a two-bit con man
who comes to town to kind of help save the dying
corn yeah turns out spoiler alert I don't know how
to save the dying corn and uh High Jinx and Sue I
kind of get roped into a potential wedding which
is kind of what the song is about that you'll see
and yeah um yeah but that's me I'm Gordy okay
and I so you're not nice okay I'm nice I'm the
villain with a nice little heartful turn at the
end yes he does it really well yeah oh I love
Redemption Redemption I play Storyteller number
two in the show which sounds sounds so lackluster
sounds like an extra but it's not and one of the
the one he's one of the biggest characters of the
show we just couldn't think of an when I got the
audition I was like it's Storyteller number two
huh like Barista 3 and Gilmore Girls but um I am
I am one of the narrators yeah the the gay one
I love you so much I can see why you got hired
right off the bat okay you're making oh Glow's
going to hate me my makeup artist okay so wait
so you have a tradition at the show right I love
this tradition so we share a dressing room at our
theater and every week we award someone something
called the shucky which is this like uh little
statue John crafted with his children right and um
we give it every week to it's like employee of the
week and so we give it every week to someone that
has gone like above and beyond in the building
and we would like to do our weekly award here
on air if we could do we have the shuy so here it
is oh my God it's corn John made at home um with
hand painted and mounted from some old thing
I had in my house and he's prepared a speech
Kelly we are so thankful that you chose to break
away from Los Angeles the West Coast has been a
little less bright since you've been gone but New
York is stronger with you in it the chemistry is
real all I ever wanted was for shuck to be the
first Broadway show to perform on your show in
a moment like this I don't know the meaning of
life my God but gratitude has got got to be part
of it so we made the shucky piece by piece and
now we present it to you thank you so now shucky
in hand when Christmas comes around and you're
underneath the tree you can tell yourself this is
my December this is M it's my that was good the
M thank you so much my life would shop without
you is that amazing he said my life
would shook without you and I would
like to thank Texas and who El for all of
us just raising all of us what's funny is
I really assumed I was the one getting the
shule I even moved up you're you like ready
for your moment got the emotional face not
your time it's my time it's my time like
[Music]
Goonies [Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a
great night I'm going home